et hop une heure on embrasse jean mika
pas pu être aujourd'hui pour des raisons
personnelles qui sera de retour bien sûr
lundi mon jour en tout cas avec ses deux
premiers extraits je pense que c'est un
bon résumé des échanges hors antenne de
tpm paie un peu de séduction et surtout
beaucoup de n'importe quoi prix alors si
vous mixez les deux ça donne des
conversations enfin là ça va donner une
des grosses variations les plus
surréalistes que j'ai eu depuis le début
de la saison
ça commence par matthieu delormeau qui
dit qui voudraient du foie gras et ça
finit par damian canivet qui dirait pas
non à isabelle morini bosc
comment en est on arrivé là en même pas
30 secondes la réponse en images
jeanne je vais j'y arrive pas
[Musique]
et
oh
[Musique]
mon bâton
c'est vrai débat dont je vois ici manche
un tas d'autres défendent les vaches les
messieurs dames et soldats
alors oui sûrement il a dit à ses tables
du monde sait les chambres à coucher
d'accord
j'évoque kelly alors je vous dis j'ai vu
qu'il y de revenir de là bas parce que à
chaque coupure pub
mine de rien on va pas se mentir elle va
boire parce que d'habitude à maxime
gagné là bas et elle va voir maxime
guignen passe toutes les coupures pub à
côté de maxime jean charest se passer un
truc hein les deux amours là mais
comment ça peut marcher ça comme avec
une chance de marquer sa web à ça il fut
en dessous sur elle se précipite sur lui
des clubs plus bas rive elle se
précipite sur maxime kenny barron la
non-obtention ensemble je fais un petit
week-end tous les deux a donc c'est le
bonheur apparemment anneaux qui va
sortir son petit canari non mais c'est
fou ça vous dirait qu'elle a bien sûr
fait quoi en fait une prestation en
boîte de nuit
j'essaie de me dire ça le toit du mx1
c'est en fait un mix est à la musique il
vient me voir et ça l'intéresse
maintenant il fait non non vous êtes en
train de dire qu'à une boîte de nuit qui
a payé pour vous avoir été toujours pas
l'une est bien de voir personnellement
non mais je sais que j'ai fait du mix
est bon les mariages les miss
il a fait du magimix a dû régler gaël il
a fait des trucs quad est dédié à
l'intérêt c'est vachement il veut venir
me voir
non c'est vrai que vous serez tous
jeunes mamans tout seul voilà avec vous
dans ma nantes
bien sûr et il va dormir non à jean
marie c est comme quand mx il va la
regarder dormir ce sens
bizarre bizarre
il en parlait de séduction on dit
souvent que le pouvoir attire donc vous
imaginez bien qu'en haut de la montagne
de la séduction tout seul avec les
aigles
il ya cyril hanouna donc régulièrement
un on se demande qui pourrait avoir les
faveurs de la polo à l'arrêt si bien
dessinés l'arrêter alors et c'est ce à
quoi les mecs moi je suis maquillée
briques voilà mais je vous le dis si
j'étais célibataire
franchement ici un tout la voie la seule
que je l'agressé isabelle quel menteur
les yeux dans les yeux quoi on m'avait
dit vous me l'avez dit à la plume
exactement alors là j'avoue que j'ai été
surpris parce que je me suis dit que si
kelly avait tenu à intervenir
c'est que c'était obligatoirement vrai
propres tâches m'en rappelle car autant
les autres chroniqueurs c'est des
raclures autant kelis et la droiture et
gardez donc j'ai été chercher cette
fameuse conversation entre syrie et
votre détresse et manque de bol je les
trouvais l'état je ne me rappelle plus
mais ça sent pas bon
j'étais surprise d'après vous tout
d'abord est ce que kelly a dit la vérité
non non non non non non pas pour moi oui
eh ben on vérifie
forcé à parisot
bien nourris tienne
la wii les lits n'ai pas menti
cyril lequesne isabelle alléluia qu'est
ce qu'on fait ici c'est vous qui décidez
mais je vous préviens ça sent de
rebondissements mois pour moi on est
bien là des colons gros tout de suite la
suite de l'épisode jean
il a c'est mieux
ce soir car voilà
quelque chose
[Applaudissements]
pire
pour la chose était alors
[Rires]
pour la connaissent déjà
non
c'est ici
[Applaudissements]
j'aimerais dire pourquoi c'est parce que
j'ai second contrôle de rester pour isa
est respectée là moi alors est ce que
fait madame et ses fans mais il avait
que je vous adore mais on se connaît
depuis trop longtemps vous êtes comme ma
soeur encore c'est vrai isabelle on se
connaît depuis s'il avait dû se passer
quelque chose se serait passé il ya dix
ans non allez savoir quand on me mettait
dans la merde mais bon ce que je retiens
quand même c'est que gilles et kelly par
contre c'est mort suis déçu il est ce
que ça on se dit si intéressant mais
mais ces morts et comme maxime a parlé
ce week-end à nantes j'ai l'impression
qu'il passera à l'action en 2052 j'ai
une déclaration officielle à faire cirer
je suis un petit bisou isabelle comme
bon me suis trop tard le mec est pas
bien parce que non parce que tu sais que
je t'aime weebe si on se connaît depuis
trop longtemps c'est oui c'est pas bon
ça ça ne cacherait une amitié
[Rires]
par contre kelly franchement c'est moi
qui lis pas bien mais j'ai quand même
une annonce à faire quoi
j'ai décidé de postuler à mon tour pour
qu'elle y alla s'est lancé et et moi non
non
[Rires]
walf là et je pense que j'ai mes chances
et kelly car contrairement à tous et au
coeur je faisais ce qui m'intéresse la
semaine dernière vous avez fait un test
de compatibilité que les chroniqueurs
c'est damien qui s'en était mieux sorti
vous étiez complètement à côté de la
plaque
elle s'en fout la richesse de l'ajout de
la beauté et je vous cache pas que ça
m'arrange
il ya un truc qui fait craquer kelly à
coup sûr et j'ai appris la semaine
dernière en regardant la séquence kelly
si je te parle bilan résultats péché ans
fiscale faux je vendais un koala non ça
c'est ça qui trop folle un jeu court
encore pourtant j'avais bien lu ce qui
s'est dit ce qui était à l'écran la
semaine dernière lors du test regardez
bien s'ils font des bébés se lasser des
norvégiens le test de comptabilité ya
déjà là-bas de vittel son fouet jusqu'à
ses impôts dans les ive et ma passion au
tpc c sas et les liners ces petites
phrases qui explique ce que vous avez
compris tout seul en regardant l'image
sérieux on n'a pas besoin d'autant
expliquer les choses aux gens ils
comprennent par exemple si je vous dis
benjamin castaldi mort de rire à côté de
valérie bénaïm qui se sert de sa fiche
comme un éventail d'après vous ben voilà
il n'y a pas besoin de liner
c'est réellement un pique nique
[Musique]
mais la meilleure phrase et je suis
super fier c'est très bien c'est il est
ou sud est un partenaire de son fils
serait je pense que je sois pas trouvé
mieux pour passer au top gênant ça ces
moments cours est étrange de touche pas
à mon poste
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
des amis
[Musique]
non
tu vois que tu es un des seuls à pouvoir
te permettre de mettre ça c'est vrai
ouais voilà
[Musique]
aujourd'hui hier que des gens que j'aime
c'est vrai c'est non c'est non je
déconne je dis que tout le monde sauf
trois personnes
c'est vrai nom si non je déconne et je
décore
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle n'est pas avare série là non c'est
ce que j'ai on va ça va se faire tous
les coups sûrs et certains j'ai le pif
pour ça je sais pas si c'est l'effet
peso s'est fait peur non mais elle n'a
jamais dit que je lui plaisais aux
hommes je suis pas du tout hostile à la
toujours dit ça vous l'avez toujours dit
ah ouais là doute la douce comme matisse
et isabelle elle a toujours été
amoureuse brassage alors moi je te jure
je suis passé toujours au travail qu'ils
avalent je suis pas du tout son désir
d'aller toujours kiffé jean duclavé
échappé mais ça bien gênant alors il est
vraiment triste maxi mais il pensait que
vous l'aimez vraiment mais cholet est
d'ailleurs à propos de maximiser c'est
un petit scoop ito je vais essayer de le
vendre comme louis alors je vais essayer
de les écouter c'est formidable mais la
chaîne de télévision s'est vite va
relancer des missions qu à la fois drôle
et éducative c'est pas sortir alors
l'objectif fort d'expliquer de manière
si s'impose aux enfants d être un peu
compliqué ça sera animé par maxime gay
n'y est pas jamie mais jean mi on a déjà
deux pilotes
[Musique]
un appel à témoins si vous êtes poteau
match
[Musique]
dans little bear c'est pas possible
c'est pas croyable la semaine prochaine
mais jean michel vous expliquera que la
tectonique des plaques
on s'emballe et strict alors dans des
quatre précédentes j'avais montré les
rapports très froid de gilles et maxime
way est bien bonne nouvelle ça s'arrange
non mais donc tout le monde aime maxime
sait rien non toute la vérité lui hein
quoi à qui pas du tout j'adore maxime ça
s'arrange quand même pas on est regardés
on n'est pas encore au top mais on sent
qu'une belle volonté de 2,5
[Musique]
[Rires]
je sais pas pourquoi ça prend pas entre
les deux parce que quand en plus on
s'embrasse on a envie de plaire à gilles
regardez là il avait sorti le grand jeu
en montrant ses talents de magicien les
yeux ébahis de damien canivet zh alors
damiens vous allez voir c'est un peu le
complice au bonneteau qui essaie
d'épater le pigeon vous allez voir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
les journées
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
maxime bellemin tour la rapide aux parts
de marché un petit tour à tout le public
non avec le bébé il va faire disparition
sa passion elle elle est folle de vous
sans rigoler elles vous font un bond des
mois jusqu'à sa nomination qu'il adore
ça et qu'il est très fort mais comment
tu sais tout ça toi a laissé des tours
n'avait pas compris qui passe je vous le
dis et que la pub se termine elle va
aller retrouver maxime comme s'il venait
la chercher à la sortie de nuit c'est
vous savez vous pas qu'on attend les
enfants en même temps pour mac et je
sais pas si c'est très intelligent de
faire disparaître les bagues évidemment
21h20 vous devez pas être coaché ouais
alors c'est compliqué un crayon voiliers
de la manie d'accord je vois pas de
concentration évidemment
à lewes la vallée pour le policier et le
bureau ont tous les détails du monde où
il est où le stylo il est en tout cas
rapide un petit truc avec des trucs
rapide
ouais à illéla le silo
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'adore ça lui plaît cela dort à la
belle qui va essayer moi c'est anne
spreads à fait d'accord t'as bien là
dessus telus est non
ouais frère non mais tu publies tes
complices écran facial et des fermes et
saint gobain complice et ses biens a
vraiment disparates way you may use view
c'est bien une idée mais le galilée
réponse il a travaillé avant la fin de
la chronique de jean luc lahaye c'est
bientôt fini
mais franchement frères as-tu conrad
huey la santé comme ça devant un public
c'est vrai c'est vrai prépare-t-on prime
ils comprennent qui va arriver bientôt
ici oui oui c'est vrai merci on a
quelque chose en tête l'a déjà ouais
c'est quoi ouais c'est un mec tout le
public tout bichr aimerait ça fait un
tour de magie toutes les quatre actifs
et avec les téléspectateurs
d'après packard disparaît d'une feuille
de papier quand même relève le plectre
héros voit le gars il s'enflamme et avec
les gages ces jeux et même à kaga des
états unis elle me toit fermé parce que
là tu es tu vas tu vas te tu vas partir
en cacahuète et par qui bonjour lui
alors il est temps de passer à tout ce
que n'avait pas voulu voir et entendre
cette semaine et on commence par keen v
qui ne parlait du tatouage qui s'était
fait faire l'occasion de la sortie de
son septième album
[Musique]
en fait un set tout simplement
c'est le septième album si vous avez
quoi d'autre à 6 1 6 1 5 à l'inventaire
0 c'est sur le cul surtout d'être aussi
sympa je suis content de voir son
émission c'est un carton absolu on a
jeté comme ça en plus j'ai une grippe
je vous raconte pas ah bon ah mais oui
j'ai eu la grippe j'étais malade je n'ai
pas bien accueilli des voix vous étiez
alité quatre enfants toi quatre enfants
mais doux avec jeunes bits
c'est un truc j'ai de ma sommet avec le
dictionnaire ressemble de plus en plus à
la chatte de l'invité
[Applaudissements]
tu veux boire des analyses d'urines
merapi c'est parti on attendait m'avoir
rien que ma voix le nrj arrive dans le
chatt nick s'appelle de l'énergie
[Applaudissements]
et vous avez eu la deuxième meilleure
note hier quand vous avez une bonne
émission à 6 juin oui très bonne ah oui
papa rapport aux autres
[Applaudissements]
il adore la suite des 4 as karim et puis
les vagues single yeah ce qu'on voulait
nous faire votre tour de match
absolument se tenir à vos côtés
bien sûr vous sortez bon il est bonne à
excellente saluent les bons boutons
week-end alors oui vous avez joué les
quelques spectateurs également vous
allez place et vous demain de la même
manière que moi tellement malaisie très
bien les issues de secours se trouve à
la bhl à présent vous a laissée aux
portes à présent vous allez les tournées
à l'intérieur comme ça comme ça très
bien à présent vous allez les accroche
et de cette manière
et toc et là vous serrez bien fort bien
fort bien vente au public les
téléspectateurs également venir former à
bord mais nous sommes gâtés à 3 ou fait
pareil que moi
wen est bien à 2,3 et vous replacer j'en
ai marre naturellement
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
les cherry est une soirée dès lors des
quatre heures de jean luc lemoine lui
que tout ce qu'on vient de voir était
fabuleux et tout ce qu'on a vu depuis le
début de l'année est fabuleux c'est le
meilleur des quatre heures de vol
[Applaudissements]